that's the beauty of Zang mode is like I  I don't know who I'm playing so I'm I  don't get too afraid of the opponent's  username or title or rating  okay top 20.  London time  ah this one  it's been trendy recently  B6 B3  and C3  I'm playing a little bit timidly here  just C4 Queen D2  um  A3  nice six  or that  this is going terribly wrong  maybe I can salvage this  is some Knight D5 idea  work B1 first  guy hunger Rook I thought it was being  clever too  [Music]  and still have some time advantage  not good though  wait what  what is this  um  foreign  trying to fight it  not easy though  foreign  There Goes My Rook uh what to do  oh I was playing Hans Neiman  I was playing Hans oh wow good game  oh Hans crushed my London  ah  oh he's top ten too  I love playing  yeah if I knew who I was playing I would  have been um I've I probably would have  played a lot worse it was hard to play  worse than what I just did there  uh good game Hans